and welcome to my video series of
molecular biology explained in three
minutes where I explain a concept in
molecular biology in less than three
minutes or so if you haven't yet
subscribed to my channel hit the
subscribe button these videos are not so
detailed but it has all the necessary
information which could save your ass in
the day of your exam and I'm also
present in an Academy which is India's
biggest online learning platform in
order to join an academy you can use my
code to get 10% discount my quad is a
p10 now let's talk about DNA ligase
DNA ligase is one of the most important
enzyme used day to day in molecular
biology lab it simply creates a
phosphodiester bond between a juxtaposed
five prime phosphate
and three prime hydroxyl termini of a
DNA now it used ATP for its function so
in this video we'll look at how exactly
DNA like is work and mode of catalysis
of TNA like is so stay tuned to the end
of this video in replication the
polymerase progressed in five prime to
three prime direction and synthesized
the strands be the leading strand or
lagging strand in a template in a primer
dependent manner so you need to have a
primer on back of which the polymer is
polymerizing it now at the end of the
replication this primers which is marked
in yellow here is removed by certain
enzymes but a cap remains between the
last two nucleotides and this gap
between two ribose sugar is basically a
phosphodiester bond so you have an open
3 prime hydroxyl terminus at one side
and it really need to get sealed and
forming a phosphodiester bond which is
performed by the DNA ligase now DNA
ligase is a day-to-day enzyme used in
molecular biology lab which is
exclusively using cloning techniques you
remember the cloning technique workflow
so first you have to restrict digestion
your vector then you can restriction
digest your gene of interest
followed by there is a DNA ligation step
when you insert your gene of interest
inside the vector and then you can
transform it into an e.coli and then the
growler Ecola in bulk as the e.coli grow
your gene of interest also amplify
now how DNA like is work DNA like is
first you use ATP so it forms a complex
with the ATP at the first now ATP binds
very near to the active site of the DNA
ligase and forms a ATP ribose at a kind
of thing now after that the three prime
hydroxyl group is the key player in this
process because key the three prime
hydroxyl group of the open strand here
works like a nucleophile which attacks
the DNA the active site of the enzyme
where there is a phosphate group and
ultimately with a molecular
rearrangement this phosphodiester bond
is formed between the five prime
terminus and the three prime open
hydroxyl group and that is how a
phosphodiester bond is formed by the DNA
ligase and when the DNA ligase forms the
phosphodiester bond it gets disengaged
from the DNA strand and the DNA strand
is finally ligated and having the
phosphodiester bond so in lab how we do
is like take purified plasmid put it in
your reaction mixture tube then you take
insert which is your vector and
generally you put more insert than the
vector and in a 1 is 2 3 or 1 is to 5
ratio and you incorporate it into the
tube then you add the like as enzyme and
the buffer which contains ATP because
ATP is SuperDuper important for this
ligation step without ATP like this
cannot work and then you put it in the
tube after that you incubate it for some
time and expect the ligation reaction to
happen generally you can cube it
overnight or say let's say for a half an
hour and then you can really check that
the ligation to place or not by running
it in agarose gel in this particular
example you can see the first line has a
insert and the vector which is only
vector restriction digested vector is
coming ana at a shifted location because
it is bigger than the insert but see the
last line where the recombinant plasmid
is there having the vector they having
the insert inside the vector so that
recombinant vector right now can be
distinguished in the agarose gel yet for
a cc of the lock like is from is
successful then you can do a quick
transformation and wait for overnight to
get a recombinant colony and that is how
you perform the cloning experiments
right and if you liked this video give
it a quick sound thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you